now that we've spent a couple of videos
exploring a scenario where I'm taking
multiple free-throws and figuring out
the probability of making K of the
scores in six attempts or in n attempts
let's actually define a random variable
using this scenario and and see if we
can construct its probability
distribution and we'll actually see that
it's a binomial distribution so let's
define the random variable X so let's
say that X is equal to the number the
number of made shots number of made free
throws when taking when taking six free
throws so it's how many of the six do
you make and we're going to assume what
we assumed in the first video in this
series of this these making free throws
so we're going to assume the 70 percent
free throw probability right over here
so assuming assumptions assuming 70
percent free-throw free-throw percentage
all right so let's figure out the
probabilities of the different values
that X could actually take on so let's
see what is the probability what is the
probability that X is equal to zero that
even though you have a 70 percent
free-throw free-throw percentage that
you make none of the shots and actually
you could you could calculate this
through to probably some common sense
without using all of these fancy things
but just to make things consistent I'm
going to write it out so this is going
to be this is going to be it's going to
be equal to six choose zero times zero
point seven to the zeroth power times
zero point three to the sixth power and
this right over here is going to end up
being one this over here is going to be
end up being one and so you're just
going to be left with zero point three
to the sixth power and I calculated it
ahead of time so if we just round to the
nearest if we do if we were on our
percentages to the nearest tenth this is
going to give you approximately
approximately well
the decimal to the nearest to the
nearest thousandth you're going to get
something like that which is
approximately equal to zero point one
percent chance of you missing all of
them so you know roughly MSB roughly
here one in a thousand one in a thousand
chance of that happening of missing all
six free throws now let's keep going
this is fun so what is the probability
that our random variable is equal to one
well this is going to be six choose one
times zero point seven to the first
power times zero point three to the to
the six minus first power so it's a
fifth power
and I calculated this and this is
approximately 0.01 or we could say one
percent so still a fairly low
probability ten times more likely than
this roughly but still a a fairly low
probability let's keep going so the
probability that X is equal to - well
that's what our first video was
essentially so this is going to be six
choose two times zero point seven
squared times zero zero point three to
the fourth power and we saw that this is
approximately going to be zero zero
point zero six or we could say six
percent and obviously you know you could
type these things in a calculator and
get a much more precise answer but just
for the sake of of just getting a sense
of what these probabilities are look
like and that's why I'm giving these
these rough estimates kind of I guess
you could say to the close to the
closest maybe tenth of a tenth of a
percent and actually even if you round
to the closest tenth of a percent you
actually get two 6.0% and this is one
point one point Oh percent because this
we actually went to a tenth of a percent
here but let's keep going we're
obviously going to have to do a few more
of these so let me just make sure have
enough real estate all right so the
probability that our random variable is
equal to three is going to be six to
three and I'm sure you could probably
fill this out on your
own but I'm going to do it 0.72 the
third power times 0.3 to the 6 minus 3
which is a third power which is
approximately equal to well it's going
to be zero point one eight five or
eighteen point five eighteen point five
percent so yeah you know that's
definitely within the realm of
possibility I mean all of these are in
the realm of possibility
but it's starting to be a non
insignificant probability now let's do
the probability that our random variable
is equal to four well it's going to be
six choose four times zero point seven
to the fourth power times zero point
three to the 6 minus four or second
power which is equal to this is going to
get equal to or approximately because I
am taking away a little bit of the
precision when I write these things down
zero point three to four so
approximately 32 point four percent
chance of making exactly four out of the
six free throws all right two more to go
let's see I have not used purple as yet
so the probability that our random
variable is equal to five it's going to
be six choose five or zero at times I
should say zero point seven to the fifth
power times zero point three to the
first power and that is going to be
roughly roughly zero point three zero
three which is 30.3% that's interesting
one more left so the probability that I
make all of them of all six is going to
be equal to is equal to six choose six
and zero point seven to the six power
times the zero point three to the zeroth
power which is this right over here is
going to be one this is going to be one
so it's really just zero point seven to
the sixth to the sixth power and this is
approximately zero
point 1 1 8 I calculated that ahead of
time which is eleven point eight eleven
point eight percent and so there's
something interesting that's going on
here the first time we looked at the
binomial distribution we said hey you
know there's the symmetry as we kind of
got to some type of a peak and went down
but why don't see that symmetry here and
the reason why you're not seeing that
symmetry is that you are more likely to
make a free-throw than not is so you
have a seventy percent free-throw
probability here this is no longer just
flipping a fair coin where you will see
the symmetry is in these coefficients if
you calculate these coefficients six
choose zero is one six choose six is one
you would see that six choose one is six
and six choose five is six you'd see six
choose two is fifteen and six twos 4 is
also 15 and then 6 choose 3 is 20 so you
definitely see you definitely see the
symmetry in the coefficients but then
these things are weighted by the fact
that you're more likely to make
something than miss something if if
these were both point five then you
would also see the symmetry right over
here and you can plot this to
essentially visualize what the
probability distribution looks like for
this example and I encourage you to do
that to take these different cases just
like we did in that first example with
the fair coin and plot these but this
essentially does give you the
probability distribution for for the
random variable in question this is I
just wrote it out instead of just
visualizing it but it says okay well
well so these are these are the
different values that this random
variable can take on it can't it can't
take on negative one or it can't be 15.5
or PI or or 1 million these are the only
seven values that this random variable
can take on and I've just given you the
probabilities or I guess you could say
the rough probabilities of the random
variable taking on each of those each of
those seven values